اعلن حزب الله تنفيذ خمس عمليات ضد مواقع
وتجمعات للجنود الاسرائيليين عند الحدود
الجنوبيه للبنان وقال الحزب انه قصف
مبنيين في مستوطنه المناره ردا على
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على منازل
المدنيين في جنوب لبنان كما قصف الحزب
موقع المرج وتجمع للجنود قرب موقع العباد
وقال الحزب انه قصف ثكنه زبدين وموقع
رويسات العلم في مزارع شبعه المحتله وتلال
كفر شوبه المحتله
في الاثناء شنت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
غاره على بلده ميس الجبل واستهدفت مسيره
اسرائيليه بالصواريخ في بلده استهدفت بلده
بليده وتعرض محيط عده بلدات حدوديه جنوبيه
لبنان لقصف مدفعي اسرائيلي ورصدت كاميرا
الجزيره لحظه اطلاق الدفاعات الجويه
الاسرائيليه صاروخا في سماء مرغلي وت بعد
لحظات من اطلاق صافرات الانذار
فيها معنا من ابل السقي جنوبيه لبنان
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي ومن الجليل
الاعلى مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود للاطلاع
على اخر التطورات وابدا معك
ايهاب حزب الله تبنى هجوما ثانيا على موقع
رويسات العلم الذي كان هجمه ايضا خلال
فتره بعد ظهر هذا اليوم وهذا الموقع الذي
يقع قباله بلده كفرشوبا هو من احد المواقع
المتقدمه ما للجانب الاسرائيلي قرب مزارع
شبعه اللبنانيه المحتله قرب هذا الموقع
هناك ثكنه زبدين ايضا استهدفها حزب الله
بالاسلحه المناسبه وهي ثكنه مهمه في تلك
المنطقه نظرا لموضعها او لموقعها الفاصل
بين شبعه اللبنانيه المحتله وبين الجولان
السوري المحتل ايضا حزب الله شن عمليات
اخرى اطلق فيها الصواريخ الموجهه والقذائف
باتجاه مواقع اخرى من جنوب لبنان اللافت
في هذه العمليات بان حزب الله اعلن انه
استهدف منزلين في مستوطنه المناره قباله
بلده ميس الجبل هذا الاستهداف ربما لا
يكون الاول من نوعه خلال الايام الماضيه
لكنه كان لاول مره يستهدف منزلين دفعه
واحده بعد ان قامت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه خلال اليومين الماضيين بتدمير
منزلين اول في ميس الجبل والثاني في بريده
هذا هذا الامر يعود بالبيانات التي كان
اعلنها في السابق حزب الله وحذر من اي
استهداف لمنازل المدنيين سيقابل بمثله
بالاعمال العسكريه التي يقوم بها حزب الله
وبمناسبه والطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
شنت ايضا اليوم غرات على اطراف بلده ميس
الجبل والطيران المسير غار على اطراف
بليده حزب الله نع اثنين من مقاتليه بعد
هجوم الليله الماضيه من قبل القوات
الاسرائيليه على منز زل يتحصنون به كما
شيعت حركه امل اثنين من مقاتليها وحركه
امل هي تنظيم محلي يتراس رئيس البرلمان
نبيه بري وصف بيان النعي هؤلا او هذين
الشخصين بالمجاهدين مما يدل على انهم
يتبعان للجهاز العسكري لحركه امل حزب الله
اصدر وبعد 120 يوما لبدء عمليات القتال في
جنوب لبنان ارقاما جديده للعمليات التي
شنها هو تحدث عن انه شن نحو
960 هجوما على مواقع اسرائيليه مختلفه قدر
حزب الله وفقا ل الارقام التي اعلنها
الاعلام الحربي التابع له عدد القتلى
والجرحى الاسرائيليين بنحو 2000 طبعا حزب
الله تحدث عن تدمير كلي او جزئي ل 500
منزل في المستوطنات الاسرائيليه قباله
الحدود اللبنانيه وايضا اشار الى انه تمكن
من اطلاق الصواريخ وال القذائف الموجهه
باعماق مختلفه داخل ال الحدود الاسرائيليه
الشماليه واشار الى ان 46 موقعا استهدفهم
حزب الله مرات ومرات بلغ عدد الاستهدافات
للمواقع الاسرائيليه وحدها وهي المحاذيه
للحدود نحو
670 هجوما خلال ال 120 يوما الماضيه حزب
الله كان تحدث ايضا عن انه استخدم اسلحه
متنوعه لكن اللافت فيها ان ال معظم هذه
الاسلحه كانت من الصواريخ الموجهه اذ قام
حزب الله باكثر من
385 استهدافا بهذه الصواريخ تلتها
المدفعيات مدفعيات الهاون ومن ثم الصواريخ
الارض ارض التي استخدمها بكثافه وهو تحدث
عن استخدام نحو 23 مسيره للانقضاض على
المواقع الاسرائيليه في جنوب لبنان